hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 3 video we're
all like you know making that face like
so make sure you watch the episode just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet I know it's not much consolation
just because everyone's freaking out so
much but there is a new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's just a $20 Amazon gift
card if you win you can use it to pay
for your therapy so let's just go ahead
and start with it starting with top 5
WTF number 5 the super hurt splits in
half with Daryl Sasha and Abraham
leading the pack ahead
although Rick kind of splits off to to
help with the first half the second half
is heading towards Alexandria if you
remember the gunshots they heard in the
episode this is essentially happening in
the same timeframe as last week's
episode I guess you can't blame him too
much for wanting to get as much mileage
out of the super hurt as possible like
it's not gonna be a two episode open and
closed matter but the most notable thing
in this opening scene is all these
SafeZone randos just like people you've
never seen before
clearly going to be the Walker bait in
the episode usually when there's a
situation like this you can kind of tell
who's gonna die first based on who's the
biggest [ __ ] who is the least helpful
who runs off on their own like who's
selfish the message here is like don't
don't be selfish when [ __ ] hits the fan
because you're gonna die first which is
why I think Daryl is kind of safe
because at the end of the episode
instead of doing the selfish thing and
going back to the safe zone he turns
around goes back to help Sasha and
Abraham on the number 4 Michonne's group
heads into the pet store and they
develop a plan to deal with the second
half of the super PAC really the whole
episode I think is about this it's about
what happens to Michelle's group because
in each episode it's like the group
keeps splitting because in the first
episode the a team splits the group and
half like the entire safestone it in
half it goes to do with the super PAC
the B team in episode 2 has to deal with
the Wolves then in episode 3 the a team
splits in half so it's like in each
successive episode the groups of been
getting smaller and smaller
just more spring cleaning for the show
like getting rid of a bunch of random
just to let you know that there are
still threats it wouldn't be the Walking
Dead if they didn't cast a bunch of
temporary Rando so they could kill him
off in the same episode Betsy's husband
here is pretty sympathetic he was like
the least [ __ ] of all the randos in
heath here they kind of used this pet
store moment to show you that heath is a
good person he's not like the douchebags
from the end of season 5 he's not like
Nick who's a
reformed [ __ ] but still kind of
floating on the edge of sanity this is
all set up for Heath's character like
they they really want you to like him I
think I said in last week's video he's
one of the new season regulars along
with Denise Cloyd who's like the new
doctor both characters from the comics
so this is a lot of heat set up
happening here and it's also a chance
for Michonne to remember how she used to
be it really was it's really touching
speech about how Betsy's saved that safe
zone person like I was dead she found me
she made me better than I was before
in Michonne is thinking the same thing
about Rick and the survivors you know
she was essentially she was dead to the
world she had given up and then Rick
gave her new purpose of course as they
run out of the store as predicted the
randos that had gotten like hurt or
hobbled early on end up dying off
literally the worst thing that could
happen to you as you're running away
from the super hurt is to hurt your leg
or get a cut somewhere like Rick that's
a big WTF to we could talk about on to
number three Rick cuts his hand as he's
running for the RV so everyone's
wondering here does this mean he's going
to lose his hand here's the deal so
getting cut and getting bitten are two
different things
one is worse than the other if you get
bit if it's not too bad they can heal
you but it's still worse than getting a
cut and Rick got cut by his knife so the
messages as long as he keeps it
relatively clean and gets back to the
safe zone within like an episode or two
he should be okay depending on the
timeline
they really are compressing time in
these episodes like between the end of
episode one and now it's been really
only just like an hour like it's almost
the same hour we've been seeing from
different perspectives so Rick still has
some time to get back in fix his hand
like he doesn't have to lose it on the
number two though Rick gets stuck in the
RV assaulted by wolves but looks like he
can't start it in time to escape the
super herd this is the real Rick WTF to
end on because we just saw what looked
like Glen dying so it's like does this
mean that Rick is gonna die too if they
can kill an a-list cast member they
could totally kill another one you know
as crappy as things look they're not
quite as bad as they were for Glen look
if you watch Game of Thrones I think it
was the end of season 3 with that Mesa
moment where the camera zoomed out with
all those people lifting Daenerys up
that's what it looked like when Glen
died he was completely surrounded 360
degrees rick is just being assaulted
from one side
to the RV so as long as he either bails
out the other side or starts the RV he
should be fine I feel like he's gonna be
ok they probably cut his hand took him
to the edge of death so many times just
to make you question whether or not he'd
survive I don't think they would have
done that so many times if they weren't
gonna save him but of course on my
number one WTF moment it looks like Glen
just got his guts ripped out after
Nicholas shot himself I don't know about
you guys but usually in situations like
that you know my brain shuts down just a
little bit he goes into survival mode
and I try to start rationalizing it like
oh okay you know he didn't die because
XYZ like you try to start jumping
through the mental hoops that it takes
to make Glen survive then after you
can't do that you just start to go oh
Jesus start to like freak out all over
the place who's gonna deliver all the
pizza now dumbass that was really a
great way to sign off that was actually
like the first line that they had each
other when they first met way way back
and I think you know I think my favorite
Glen moment was at the end of that arc
where he's just driving out of Atlanta
screaming hell yeah having sex with
Maggie of course giant win but if you
like Glenn
roaring is he was driving away from
Atlanta was a bigger reaffirmation you
guys let me know in the comments what is
your favorite all-time Glenn moment and
did you try to rationalize his death
like do you think he's actually dead I
do kind of think that he is but it's
totally possible that the guts you see
being pulled out belonged to Nicholas
like is if Nicholas landed on top of him
the other thing too that I thought might
end up happening is is just you know
just because Glenn had turned around to
go back to the safe zone just because he
was so worried one Rick saw the baby
food I felt like he was just gonna lose
his [ __ ] and turn right around but
remember the big message in the episode
is is you do the selfish that you make
the selfish choice you're gonna die
everybody that made selfish choices
ended up dying and Nick selfish choice
of committing suicide that even got
Glenn killed or at least looks like it
got Glen killed so depending on the move
that Rick makes at the beginning of next
week's episode will determine what ends
up happening to his hand I think I don't
think that he's gonna lose his hand but
you could totally argue either way I
will say stylistically I didn't like
this episode quite as much as the other
two episodes I feel like last week was a
more rewarding episode like it was like
a bigger reaffirmation like everyone was
like screaming hell yeah and the air
just because Kara was such a badass and
Morgan was such a Jedi but this
was still an amazing episode even if I
was a little disappointed in the way
they let Glenn die if you are really
freaked out about the fact that they
they haven't confirmed that Glenn is
dead they'll definitely answer that
definitively next week like you'll find
out what happened to Rick we'll find out
what happened to Glenn this is like the
really hard thing that the show has to
do now it's in its sixth season so it's
like how do you let people know that
there are still threats how do you make
them still poop their pants without
killing the main cast members I don't
even know if that's possible anymore
like every once in a while you do have
to kill someone off Tyrese is a good
example that he's starting to get a
little more overpowered he's started to
get a little bit more Zen so it's like
okay he's too powerful we had to kill
him I wouldn't say that Glenn is
overpowered though but what is this
gonna do to Maggie they did say that she
was gonna get a much bigger arc this
year through Denise is a bit of an
authority figure most of my favorite
Maggie moments are Maggie being crazy so
of course if Glenn is dead she's gonna
lose her [ __ ] but I think there's a
really interesting direction to take the
character usually it's actors they get
really excited about that like it gets
really boring when everything is alright
all the time when everything is just
like rosy fields it's not a melodrama
it's not Pride and Prejudice and Zombies
but Michonne wiping that message off of
her arm you're getting home is very
telling you could take that in the
literal way because of all the people
that died like they are literally not
getting back to the safe zone and you
could take it as a metaphor because as
they walk up to the same stone they see
like all the damage that the Wolves have
done so literally their home has been
broken you can go back to the place
where you live but you can't go home
it's not home anymore it's not the home
that you remember you can't go back to
that but if there's anything to feel
good about I feel like it's this moment
where Daryl rides back to Abraham and
Sasha as sad as the music was at the end
of the episode it was the least sad here
with this big epic wide shot so let's
all scream internally and talk about
Glenn in the comments everybody just let
me know like you could still argue
either way but it definitely looks like
he is dead the interesting thing though
is that he didn't go on talking dead I
think that's because he's either
shooting something he was either
unavailable or they purposefully don't
want to confirm whether or not he's dead
congratulations to Jimmy woo you win
last week's Walking Dead giveaway is a
$20 Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I get your contact info feel free to
use it towards your therapy bill so
continue to scream you can click here
for all my other Walking Dead videos and
you can click here for the Jessica Jones
trailer which will make you cry for a
completely different reason David
Tennant will totally make you cry thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five go go hug somebody you love
I'll see you tomorrow